foreign
[Music]
to the naked eye our world appears
orderly and stable
a glass of water resting on the table
looks still but if you zoom in on the
atoms and molecules that compose the
water you would see that actually they
are moving
the microscopic world of fluids is
animated by countless particle
collisions moving atoms and molecules on
wandering trajectories
this random movement of particles is
called Brownian motion
in 1827 botanist Robert Brown first
discovered this phenomenon after
observing that pollen grains Jitter
would immersed in water
for several decades it was unclear why
small particles would dance when
suspended in a fluid
some scientists thought that there was
some sort of Life Force driving this
movement since pollen comes from Plants
but it was soon discovered that
non-living materials like dust and iron
filings exhibit the same jiggly Behavior
in 1905 the mystery began to unravel
Albert Einstein modeled the motion of
Brown's pollen particles as a result of
being bombarded by individual water
molecules
in Einstein's model the water molecules
bombard a pollen grain from different
directions some directions more than
others resulting in its seemingly random
motion
while ancient Greeks and Romans had
theorized about atoms and molecules
Einstein's work validated the Century's
old idea that units of matter too small
for our eyes to see actually do exist
by understanding Brownian motion
Einstein was also able to accurately
determine the size of atoms and
molecules
Brownian motion can explain a wide range
of processes such as the movement of
bacteria and proteins the diffusion of
calcium through our bones
the spread of pollutants through air and
water and even the movement of viral
particles through the air
scientists also use mathematical models
of Brownian motion to describe
fluctuating social phenomena such as
stock prices
the transmission of disease throughout a
community
and the spread of rumors in social
networks
this is because human behaviors like
Brownian motion involve Randomness many
of the decisions we make about things
like buying stock or socializing are
influenced by a combination of
innumerable complex factors such as the
weather
what we ate for breakfast or whether our
neighbor said hello to us on the street
Browning in motion also plays a central
role in recent and emerging Technologies
particularly those that depend on the
process of diffusion the movement of
particles from an area of high
concentration to an area of low
concentration
Brownian motion is integral to
understanding diffusion since the latter
involves small particles suspended in a
fluid
exciting applications of diffusion
include generating energy from solidity
differences designing dialysis machines
for removing waste products from blood
creating batteries for storing energy
and desalinating water to make it
potable
despite operating on a minuscule scale
Brownian motion is fundamental to
understanding how our world functions
and it will continue to play an
important role in the technologies that
will shape our future
[Music]
foreign